both delegations led by the afghan
government side and the taliban side
have met the emir of qatar
there are intra-delegation talks which
are scheduled
but right now both of these delegations
are deciding who is going to be meeting
whom
and to discuss that further we have with
us one member of the delegation mrs
habib
thank you very much for being with us uh
describe to us
how hopeful are you that this talks are
going to yield some results
and what is going to be the future plan
of action
thank you
we are here to have this talk
in discussion that's why this is the
reason that we came from along from
afghanistan to doha
for this talk and then the the people of
afghanistan desire for that talk and
looking forward to
this talk could be happen and also
now we have the support of all the
international community all the the
the country in the region that this talk
should be
uh happen so that's why we are
uh we hope we do have hope for that and
the result of course
it's a long way to go and we will have a
long discussion and
also uh of course that will be not very
easy
uh it's a bumpy road uh but we will see
the result
your your delegation has decided it's
going to be a six-member contact
committee
which is going to be meeting with the
taliban first setting out the agenda
and on monday is going to be the first
day probably of these intra-afghan
dialogue
i think so yeah tomorrow uh which is the
which is monday the the the two
delegation from both sides the
delegation from both sides will sit
together
and talk about the some code of conduct
the procedure rule and procedure and
also the agenda
setting the agenda how hopeful are you
because as a woman member of the
delegation
somebody who's representing one of the
many minorities
in afghanistan do you think that after
20 years
nearly 20 years of conflict you will be
able to convince the taliban
to give up violence and listen to you
for what you want
there is no further reason that we the
both sides should continue for
for war and for conflict we have to sit
together to talk there is no solution
for that
the best solution the better solution is
to sit together to talk
politically our our issue our problem
and also putting our ideal and agenda
at the table and talk about that and to
get some result of that
but you see that this is a very
difficult situation uh
even today the afghan government is
saying there have been more than 18
attacks
in the last 24 hours in in various
provinces
the taliban is saying that there is a
propaganda campaign that is being run
against them
so there is a lack of trust and it seems
to be quite
wide on both sides how are you going to
be able to bridge that
uh there is lack of trust of course it's
it's it's common for every
peace talk every peace negotiation
this lack of trust can be happen but
unfortunately
uh of course there is no
evidence from taliban side to say that
it's a propaganda
because we have the evidence we have
the fire that happened to the area or
the
blasting or or conflict
so but anyway we have uh yesterday we've
got some
a positive gesture it can be a a step
forward for the
building the trust we have to build the
trust i think
here and qatari in qatar also
uh uh we have to to to do some
gesture or to to show some positive uh
uh to take some positive uh step for
building the trust thank you very much
for speaking to us and there you have it
this is
the view from the afghan delegation that
yes there has been violence that there
might continue to be violence but
they're hopeful that this
level of trust that does not exist
between them is going to be built
as contact groups begin the negotiations
the intra afghan dialogues without
international interlocutors
we've been hearing from diplomats saying
that they are still here
they're still supporting it but from a
back seat
it is going to be weeks and months
before this could yield results
but both sides are hopeful that this is
a first step
in the right direction